in diesem video erfährst du wie du deine
tomaten aus geiz bei welchen pflanzen
man das machen sollte bei welchen man es
sein lassen sollte warum das bei einigen
pflanzen so wichtig ist wie das ganze
funktioniert und wann man das macht also
alles rund ums thema tomaten aus geiz
oder zeige ich dir den besten weg wie du
das machen kannst du dass deine pflanzen
möglichst gesund bleiben was ihnen
großen ertrag abwerfen und dass die
früchte auch möglichst aromatisch
schmecken ich habe dieses jahr noch ganz
viele andere tomaten videos geplant die
euch wirklich durch das ganze jahr
führen sollen so dass ihr immer wisst
was man bei euren tomaten an steht also
drückt gerne den abo button und auch die
glocke damit ihr informiert werden
sobald die nächsten videos erscheinen
damit ich euch am besten weiter helfen
kann eure besten tomatenernte überhaupt
kein zu waren dieses jahr ändert mittels
gibt
[Musik]
wir sind jetzt hier zwar im gewächshaus
aber du musst natürlich auch freiland
tomaten oder tomaten die du auf dem
balkon anbaus geilsten auch sei es sind
bush tomaten oder zwerg tomaten aus
tomaten muss man nicht ausgereizten die
kommen damit klar dass sie ganz viele
unterschiedliche betriebe haben
das liegt daran dass bush tomaten und
zwerg tomaten eine bestimmte anzahl von
früchten genetisch bilden können und
wenn du die ausgereizt dann nimmst du
eben quasi die hälfte der möglichen
früchte weg die fallenden einfach weg
bei den anderen tomaten ist das nicht so
da ist es dann nicht so dass wenn man
einen geist trieb rausnimmt dass die
pflanze dann insgesamt weniger tomaten
produziert im gegenteil die bleibt
gesünder
die konzentriert ihre ganze kraft in die
triebe die frucht ansätze die man eben
stehen lässt und ist viel luftiger das
ist auch wichtig weil tomaten ja sehr
anfällig sind für die crowd freude da
muss man immer darauf achten dass
dazwischen luft zirkulieren kann
und deswegen ist es total sind tomaten
aus zu geizen außer es sind eben busch
tomaten oder zwei automaten bei denen
würde das keinen sinn ergeben weil man
sich damit die ernte ein kürzt sozusagen
aber die anderen tomaten also alle fast
alle tomatensorten muss man ein tri big
erziehen man kann die auf zwei triebe
kerzengerade im gewächshaus ergibt das
denn das macht man aber normalerweise
eher mit veredelten tomaten das kann man
natürlich auch zu hause ausprobieren
aber das ist eher was für den
professionellen tomatenanbau zu hause
würde ich schon jedem empfehlen die
tomaten ein trick zu erziehen wir werden
uns jetzt einfach mal eine
tomatenpflanze anschauen damit ihr
vielleicht besser versteht was es mit
diesen trieben auf sichert und wie man
denn die getriebe findet die man da
entfernen soll also jetzt unsere
tomatenpflanze und die hat hier einen
stamm und davon gehen blätter ab und
zwischen diesen blättern und dem stamm
entstehen immer wieder kleine triebe die
sind am anfang natürlich noch winzig es
ist am besten wenn man die so früh wie
möglich raus bricht damit die pflanze da
gar nicht erst ihre energie rein lenkt
manchmal werden die aber auch richtig
groß und dann kriege ich immer
nachrichten von leuten die sagen
ich kann doch jetzt nicht diesen betrieb
entfernt erblüht ja schon also da
könnten sich doch schon jetzt tomaten
dran bilden und ich würde euch trotzdem
immer empfehlen die abzumachen die
guides triebe also da ja ich weiss es
tut manchmal weh aber es ist für die
pflanzen letztendlich besser wenn man
auch große betriebe wie der den ich euch
jetzt mal hier ein blende entfernt damit
die eben ein trick weiter wachsen und
dann wirklich die ganze power in den
früchten hat die sich an diesem einen
trieb bilden damit die pflanzen gesünder
bleiben das ist so ärgerlich diese
krautfäule die kann einem so ein strich
durch die rechnung machen
gerade im freiland bei freiland tomaten
und da ist es ganz ganz wichtig dass man
das regelmäßig macht und zwar verbessern
bevor die guides triebe so groß werden
übrigens kann man diese kurven guides
triebe wenn man in meinen großen
ausbrechen muss einfach in ein glas
wasser stehen und dann wurde sie in die
an und dann kann man wieder eine neue
tomatenpflanze aus diesen guide streep
ziehen natürlich ist es ein bisschen
spät dann jetzt noch tomaten aus streams
zu ziehen
sie werden nicht mehr so viel ertrag
abwerfen wie die die jetzt schon so
risikos sind aber die werden schon noch
früchte tragen dieses jahr
gerade gegen ende der saison wenn
vielleicht die anderen tomaten dann
schon ein bisschen schwächeln also mach
das gerne wenn ihr noch ein paar mehr
tomaten in ihrem garten haben wollt und
sieht einfach aus den betrieben
die tomatenpflanzen tut das auch gleich
kann nicht mehr so arg wie ich weiß es
oft so dass man auch mal einen guide
streep übersieht und der wird dann auf
einmal riesengroß und dann ist man ganz
überrascht und vielleicht ein bisschen
überfordert was man jetzt machen soll
deswegen um das zu verhindern um
wirklich möglichst alle getriebe zu
erwischen wenn sie noch ganz klein sind
habe ich einen trick für euch und zwar
geht die einfach einmal von oben bis
unten die pflanze durch also ihr schaut
am stängel runter in jedes blatt achsen
paar ob sich da ein geiles trieb
gebildet hat und dann geht ihr da einmal
jede blatt achse durch und so kann euch
kein geist rieb mehr durch die lappen
gehen hoffentlich manchmal passiert es
trotzdem noch ich habe ja auch so eine
moschee und den dann einfach ausbrechen
auch wenn es weh tut
ein kleiner tipp noch ich würde tomaten
wenn sie nass sind also gerade wenn ihr
vielleicht freiland tomatenanbau nicht
anfassen das ist haben wir auch auf dem
hof wo ich vorher gearbeitet habe immer
so gemacht wenn die tomaten das sind
dann lassen wir die in ruhe weil wenn
wir dann blätter ausbrechen dann können
viel besser krankheiten in die pflanze
eindringen man kann die krankheiten von
einer zur anderen pflanze übertragen
deswegen besser warten bis die pflanzen
abgetrocknet sind bevor ihr irgendwelche
pflegearbeiten an den tomaten dann
durchführt ja genau wenn man das danach
dann hat man eben diesen einen haupt
trieb den mann an der rankhilfe oder am
seil hoch führt und der dann hoffentlich
ganz viele tolle leckere tomaten
produziert die dann auch aromatischer
sind zumindest sagt man das den tomaten
nach dass wir mal sie aus dass sie mehr
die ganze süße den ganzen geschmack in
die früchte stecken die sie daneben
produzieren die werden besser reis
gerade gegen ende der saison wenn
vielleicht noch viele grüne tomaten an
deinen pflanzen hängen die kann man
natürlich nach reifen das video kann ich
euch mal da oben verlinkten aber dann
ist es eben gut wenn die pflanze die
kraft noch in die früchte reinstecken
kann die eben noch dranhängen so dass
die dann auch möglichst reif werden
und dann habe ich noch einen kleinen
trick für euch wenn ihr mal beim
ausreizen oder beim pflegen eurer
tomaten die spitze ab reicht also der
haupt trieb ist ja diese spitze hier
oben die bis zum unteren ende durchgeht
und manchmal passiert ist dass man aus
wir sehen den haupt trieb abbricht und
dann könnt ihr einen der oberen getriebe
neben stehen lassen und an eurer
rankhilfe empor leiten so dass das der
neue haupttriebwerke ich weiß gar nicht
ob ich eine tomate habe ich glaube ich
habe da hinten eine tomate gesichtet bei
der das der fall ist falls ja ich muss
mir das vielleicht noch mal genau
anschauen kann ich euch das hier
einblenden wie das dann aussieht
natürlich wirft das die pflanze ein
bisschen neben ihrer entwicklung zurück
und man sollte möglichst aufpassen dass
man der nicht wehtut aber wenn das mal
passiert dann ist das eben kein problem
einfach einen der oberen getriebe stehen
zu lassen und den als neuen hauptgegner
oben zu leiten
voila hier ist uns vor ein paar wochen
mal der haupt trieb abgebrochen an
dieser stelle hier
und dann habe ich einfach diesen betrieb
stehen gelassen und leite den jetzt
einfach an der schnur nach oben sieht
das der sich zum neuen haupttriebwerke
ltte hat und die pflanze trotzdem noch
weiter nach oben wachsen kann
da seht ihr noch mal die wunde ist alles
gut verheilt und jetzt haben wir eben
trotzdem unsere tomatenpflanze man sieht
ihr das auch von weitem gar nicht so arg
an ich werde gleich mal da drüben mein
video zum tomaten düngen ist ja jetzt
auch super wichtig dass man weiß wie man
seine tomaten sind da unten ist auch
noch ein spannendes video und wie gesagt
wenn ihr lust habt auf noch mehr tomaten
tipps wenn euch dieses video gefallen
hat dann abonniert den kanal und drückt
die glocke damit ihr bescheid bekommt
sobald das nächste tomaten video
erscheint